j'appelle soleiman balade dans mon
boulot ces artistes on va faire court je
travaille à la fois le dessin à la
peinture la vidéo ou la musique et la
photo aussi hélas que je vais présenter
bientôt à l'artothèque pour la nuit des
musées
donc c'est un travail d'installation
vidéo dans une double projection votre
j'appelle en traduction de nulle part en
même temps et qui va être accompagné
aussi d'un orchestre harmonique
[Musique]
les images que je projette c'est d'une
part par là des nuages qui se promènent
horizontalement
d'un côté donc les i enfin les nuages
pour le sait
deux représentations de la perfection
inaccessible et de l'autre côté une
image on va dire triturer l'idée c'est
de reprendre à visuellement un moniteur
4/3 qui fonctionne mal en fait et donc
ils défilent derrière espèce de
bâtiments vous verticale et puis des
parasites dans l'image même en fait qui
est qui et comment dire enneigées et
dense est dans cet écran la finance et
pour cette vidéo là en fait partie de la
vidéo cd portrait d'humains qui se
succèdent en fait dans leur quotidien
est ce que j'essaie de mettre en
évidence et leur solitude en fait même
quand ces personnes sont entourés de
[Musique]
montrez-nous par ce travail là à la nuit
des musées pense que ça me perdre mais
ça me permet en fait d'avoir un public
qui est pas le public habituel en fait
des salles d'exposition des vernissages
choses comme ça pendant que voir en une
on va dire neuf sur l'emploi
[Musique]